hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the HTC One m9 and this is the
dot view case 2.0 now a lot of you guys
probably know how I feel about cases
already especially on premium metal
smartphones like this one but I did do a
dedicated video on the first dot view
case when it came out with the m8 last
year and it was one of the more
interesting and actually most popular
first party accessories I've seen in a
while so it's back with version 2.0 for
the m9 and it's a little more
interesting a little more
eyebrow-raising than before so check
this out first of all it has a couple of
slight differences physically from the
first one it'll be available in a few
new colors and they all now have a
clearish transparent back to show off
the metal underneath now I say clear ish
because at the right angle it does have
a bit of a blue shimmery hue to it maybe
it's just me or it was just the right
light I don't know but that's what I saw
and now it actually covers more of the
rim of the phone so you're protected all
the way around all of the edges and it's
actually super snug so it's really hard
to take off once you've put it on and
the most important change to me is that
the magnets and the hinges are improved
so now it lays flat and unlike the first
one it doesn't bounce around at all when
it's closed or when it's open so the
general idea of the case here is still
exactly the same it's a flip cover with
the little poke through holes in the
front and you do have to flip it open to
use it
the magnets wake the screen and then you
sort of have to prop it open with your
free hand or a free finger while you
actually use the phone both in portrait
and in landscape so it still has all the
see-through functions where you can see
if a call is coming in and swipe the
outside of the shell itself to accept or
deny the call without ever opening the
case you can also see other
notifications like a new email or your
charging status when you're plugged in
but the update to the dot view app with
this m9 brings some legit new kind of
features to the case so first of all
there are new themes and these kind of
change the way you see the time when you
check that in dot view so you can still
use the default theme which is plain
text weather and the time but then you
have a bunch of these other colorful
pre-loaded themes so you can get a
little bit more interesting in the way
it looks when you check the time with
dot view there's also these Holly
they based pre-loaded themes I don't
know if I want to use these but you can
have them automatically activate when
the holidays arrive so if that's what
you're into you can have your phone
surprise you like that and there's also
some live themes which basically are
just short animations so if I choose one
here you can see when I apply it it
gives me a little bit of motion when I
check the time so I'm not sure how many
people still want that but it's there so
you can also make your own theme pretty
easily just hit the plus up top and then
you can actually just take a picture of
anything with the camera does a pretty
good job of reproducing it in a sort of
a dot view way so if you get a couple of
nice-looking colors some contrast in
there you can crop it set it and sure
enough from an arm's distance it
actually looks like whatever you take a
picture of and so you can do this really
quickly and easily just like that so I
made a quick theme of the facet just in
Malheur made that's on my wall right now
just by taking a picture I even did one
of the shirt I'm wearing today so if
that isn't dope and pretty easy to do I
don't know what is
now after themes you have a couple of
other things you have apps and there are
just three right now but I'd expect more
to show up in the Play Store eventually
dot messages is pretty simple lets you
pick a color text and background and
then play whatever message you type
through the dot view cover on repeat
Scrolls pretty smoothly
pretty neat even if you don't have a
purpose other than it just looking cool
and then dot design is another way to
draw your own themes so it gives you a
few free templates to trace over and
make your own drawings on the dot view
theme I'm not very good at drawing or
even tracing so I kind of stuck to the
preloaded ones with that options there
and then there's my favorite and it's
actually a game it's called HTC dot
breaker
Oh
so admittedly this probably isn't the
best gaming experience the one m9 is
capable of but it's still pretty cool
and it's something you can break out as
I guess conversation starter or to get a
while out of someone and honestly what
cooler features can you show me in a
smartphone case so I'm playing freaking
brick breaker on my phone without even
opening the case it's crazy bottom line
I have the same recommendation as last
time with this dive view case really I'm
not the biggest guy into cases on a
smartphone but if first party cases all
had this much effort put into them I'd
be very happy so thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace